[Musique]
m
je
on
[Musique]
le matin du 16 décembre 1944 le calme
des ardennes belges est soudain troublée
par le fracas de la guerre
[Musique]
les allemands déploie deux cent
cinquante mille hommes sur la ligne de
front appuyé par des centaines de chars
et autres véhicules blindés l'attak
brutale et soutenu par le feu nourri de
2000 pièces d'artillerie
[Musique]
cette offensive surprend complètement
les alliés et durant les premiers jours
elle manque de réussir
[Musique]
quand les alliés retrouveront leurs
esprits l'offensive allemande sera vouée
à l'échec
est rationnée difficultés du terrain et
problèmes d'approvisionnement
provoqueront l'échec de la dernière
grande opération militaire allemande à
l'ouest que cette puissante armée ait pu
être levé dans le plus grand secret
posera toutefois quelques questions
embarrassantes du côté des alliés et
démontrera que malgré les succès est là
le rapide des troupes de l'ouest la
défaite d'hitler ne se fera pas sans
difficultés
[Musique]
depuis que les alliés ont posé le pied
sur le sol de normandie le 6 juin 1944
un nombre d'hommes et de matériels
toujours croissant n'a cessé d'être
envoyées par cette tête de pont
pourtant plus les alliés se rapproche de
la frontière plus la résistance
allemande se durcit comme en témoignent
les rudes combats que les alliés doivent
mener dans la région d'aix la chapelle
et de la forêt de jürgen
[Musique]
les deux lignes de front commence alors
à prendre deux directions opposées
entre les deux se trouvent la paisible
région des ardennes
les troupes alliées impliqués dans les
combats de aix la chapelle et de horgen
sont envoyés dans ce secteur calme pour
se reposer et pour reformer les unités
le moral est bon et le sentiment que la
guerre sera bientôt fini plane sur les
troupes
[Musique]
après des combats de l'été 44 les alliés
ont progressé de façon spectaculaire
même s'ils ont eu besoin de sept à huit
semaines avant de commencer à avancer au
delà de la tête de pont en normandie ils
ont ensuite littéralement volé jusqu'à
la frontière allemande
en cours de route les forces armées
ennemies en europe de l'ouest sont
largement détruite il ne leur reste que
quelques unités par pie ix et çà et là
début septembre
les anglais arrivent à bruxelles le 3
septembre pour libérer la ville est de 4
septembre ils prennent anvers c'est à ce
moment là que les britanniques vont
connaître des problèmes
d'approvisionnement
ils seront forcés d'arrêter leur
progression les américains eux se sont
avancés sur un axe différents vers le
sud la troisième armée de patton arrive
sur la meuse le 1er septembre mais il
connaissait aussi des problèmes de
logistique sans fait à l'aide geste
clair ne veut plus laisser l'initiative
aux alliés il veut absolument sortir de
cette débâcle et début août il commence
à élaborer des plans pour sa contre
attaque
il pense qu'une offensive bien mené à
l'ouest pourraient forcer les alliés à
revoir leur position
sorry
hitler veut donc attaqué par les
ardennes là même où les allemands ont
écrasé les français en 1940
en attaquant par les ardennes il espère
renouveler sa victoire de 40 est ainsi
divisé les alliés
en battant les alliés par surprise il
espère pouvoir mettre un terme à leur
alliance politiquement ils pensent
qu'ils chercheront à signer un accord de
paix et qu après avoir fermé le front de
l'ouest il pourra se concentrer sur les
russes
pour le général alfred jodl les
principaux problèmes à résoudre sont la
maîtrise du ciel des alliés les
difficultés d'approvisionnement et le
secret de l'opération
pour contrer la supériorité des alliées
dans le ciel la date de l'offensive est
d'abord fixé pour fin novembre avant
d'être reculé à la mi décembre il a
toutes les raisons de penser que le
mauvais temps habituel à cette période
de l'année freinera sévèrement la
surpuissante aviation et demi
[Musique]
le secret de l'opération représente l'un
des aspects les plus délicats de
l'assaut seuls quelques officiers triés
sur le volet ont connaissance du plan et
les troupes ne sont informés des détails
du projet qu'au tout dernier moment
par ailleurs un plan de diversion est
aussi mis en place dans l'espoir de
tromper les services de renseignement
allié
pour commencer de maréchal von rundstedt
connu pour ses talents de défenseur
rappelé de retraite est nommé commandant
en chef des armées allemandes sur le
front de l'ouest pour le monde extérieur
il remplace le maréchal modèle connu
pour son côté plus agressif même modèle
continue de mettre le plan de la tacc au
point
qu'à gerd von rundstedt de revient le
1er septembre 1944 mais seulement pour
faire acte de figuration pour tromper
les alliés si leur faire croire que ce
vieil homme de 69 ans est là pour
sécuriser la frontière et qu'il est
impossible qu'il soit impliqué dans une
offensive d'envergure
jetons un drone chutait dé connu pour
être un expert de la défense
les allemands organisent leurs
diversions ouvertement
ils permettent par exemple à la
reconnaissance aérienne et demi de
repérer la sixième armée de panzers près
de cologne
dès qu'ils sont sûrs que les alliés ont
bien photographié cette unité de chars
près de cologne il l'a des places de
nuit jusqu'à sa position pour l'attack
le plan semble parfait sur papier
hitler prévoit d'envoyer une puissante
force armée blindée par la vallée de
l'amblève à travers les positions alliés
jusque anvers il espère ainsi couper le
front alliés en deux
anvers est l'un des principaux ports
utilisés par les alliés pour
approvisionner les troupes du nord ouest
de l'europe
les réserves de carburant représente un
gros problème pour les allemands
surtout avec deux fronts à défendre
l'idée d'hitler et donc de couper les
alliés de leurs principales sources de
ravitaillement pour essayer d'équilibrer
des forces en présence sur le front de
l'ouest
éclair envisage cette attaque pour
montrer aux alliés que l'allemagne peut
encore remporter une victoire alors
qu'elle semble au bord de la défaite
hitler et ses généraux décide de
surnommer cette offensive what am rhein
ce qui veut dire regarde haut rhin comme
cela ceci les alliés tombe sur une note
ou une information à propos de cette
contre attaque ils penseront simplement
avoir affaire à une opération défensive
à des mouvements de troupes le long de
la frontière pour tenter d'empêcher les
alliés d'entrée en allemagne
si le plan semble bon sur papier il est
loin d'être parfait dans la réalité les
ennemis qui se battent en ardenne en
1944 sont très différents de ceux de
les différentes armées qui se trouvent
dans la région combattre les allemands
depuis plus de cinq ans un peu partout
dans le monde
les alliés peuvent compter sur un
approvisionnement quasi illimité et sont
capables de déployer rapidement de
nouvelles troupes dans les ardennes
alors qu'hitler toi racler les fonds de
tiroir pour réunir les régiments
nécessaires à son attaque
en 1940 la vitesse d'exécution
permettait à ce type de plan de réussir
en 1940 les troupes allemandes prenait
une direction sud ouest et utiliser les
routes disponibles
cette fois ci la taxe se dirige vers le
nord ouest et celle quelques routes sont
encore ouvertes les ali ont en effet
juguler le trafic en fermant les routes
principales soient temporairement soit
définitivement du co l'assemblée des
unités blindées allemandes se trouve
ralentie par d'importants embouteillages
tout au plus les ressources allemandes
sont tout à fait inapproprié pour cette
tâche si d'un côté certaines unités de
l'armée sont aguerris et très bien
équipée d'un autre côté il y à une
multitude de soldats de second rang il
manque aussi cruellement d'artillerie de
munitions et de carburant
les unités de l'avant-garde de
l'offensive après une campus ils devront
trouver leur propre ravitaillement au
cours de l'opération
voilà donc une contre attaque qui dépend
de l'habilité de sa tête de pont à se
procurer du carburant pour continuer à
avancer
tous ces détours pour trouver le liquide
vital pour les panzers freineront la
tacc et ces retards ne laisseront que
peu de marge de manoeuvre aux troupes
allemandes pour atteindre ensuite leurs
objectifs
le temps posera aussi un problème il
clair choisi délibérément d'attaqué
pendant les mois d'hiver parce qu'il
avait de fortes chances pour qu à cette
période le climat cloud l'aviation
ennemie au sol mais il n'a sans doute
pas considérer le fait que ce temps
influencerait aussi les mouvements de
ses propres troupes à cette époque de
l'année on peut s'attendre à avoir de la
neige et essayer de déplacer un char
tigres de 68 tonnes dans ces conditions
se révèle désastreux
n'importe quel général ayant vécu
l'expérience du terrain avec ses troupes
voyons ce plan ils réagissaient tout de
suite en disant non ça ne marche pas
les seuls généraux qu'ils approuvaient
étaient des gens comme yodel
des béni oui oui
clerc s'était entouré de gens comme ça
et quand il voyait son projet ils
disaient oui ça va marcher tous les
autres affirmaient que cette offensive
allait rater
il est intéressant de citer un passage
de l'interrogatoire fait après la guerre
du général d'armée ss7 dit rich car elle
nous donne une assez bonne idée de
l'état d'esprit à cette époque
tout ce que je devais faire
ces thèmes emparé de bruxelles et
ensuite prendre le port d'anvers tous
assurent décembre janvier et février les
trois pires mois de l'année à travers
les ardennes où la neige était très
épaisse et il n'y avait pas assez de
place pour déployer 4 char de front
alors que dire de six divisions blindées
en vain ferme à cheval ou bien que le
maréchal von rundstedt commandant en
chef des armées allemandes à l'ouest et
le maréchal modèle commandant du groupe
armé b qui lancera l'offensive des
ardennes soit en désaccord sur de
nombreux points il ya une chose sur
laquelle ils sont d'accord le plan
d'hitler pour s'emparer d'anvers grâce à
ces divisions blindées et virtuellement
irréalisable ils pensent tous les deux
que les allemands devraient se contenter
d'un objectif plus limité comme un
encerclement peut-être pas de toutes les
forces britanniques et canadiennes du
nord-ouest de l'europe mais simplement
de la première armée us déployés dans le
nord des ardennes
ils sont convaincus que s'ils tendent
cela et ils pensent qu'ils peuvent
réussir le résultat sera très probants
le dernier pari d'hitler est lancée mais
la nature désespérée de la situation
semble déjà évidente sur le papier les
allemands réunis une force d' attaques
puissantes répartis sur trois armes et
la sixième armée bonne heure sous les
ordres de dietrich se situe le plus au
nord sur le front
elle date avancée par la route depuis sa
position près de dalhem en allemagne
jusqu'en belgique et la région de los
shame son objectif est de traverser la
meuse
juste en dessous de liège et de
continuer jusque anvers
à côté de la sixième armée se trouve la
5ème armée panzer commandés par le
lieutenant général aso vonlanthen
son objectif est de partir de primes en
allemagne jusqu'en verse en passant par
bruxelles
[Musique]
la 7e armée sous la direction du général
éric brandenburger doit partir plus au
sud jusqu'au luxembourg
l'objectif de cette unité d'infanterie
partie de bitburg en allemagne est
d'engager le combat contre la troisième
armée us et d'immobiliser ses troupes
toutes ces armes et font partie du
groupe armé b commandé par le maréchal
modèle
le total de ces forces s'élève à plus de
250 mille soldats et près de 1000 chars
et autres canons autotracté dans les
jours à venir ces forces vont poser de
sérieux problèmes aux alliés
de l'avant garde allemande sont de
différentes qualités si les division ss
panzer comprennent des officiers
d'expérience un grand nombre de ses
soldats sont d'anciens hommes de l'armée
de l'air ou de la marine
auclair fait donc muté des marins dans
des divisions d'infanterie du personnel
de l'armée de l'air dans des divisions
parachutistes et il crée les divisions
de volts grenadière composée d'hommes
venant de toutes sortes d'horizon de
jeunes adolescents et de vieux
[Musique]
les allemands ont réussi à rassembler
leurs unités de combat dans les ardennes
en déplaçant leurs troupes comme s'il
prévoyait une offensive des alliés
et se préparer à les contrer
quand les analystes des services secrets
alliés observe les mouvements de troupes
en face
ils sont persuadés que les allemands ont
déjà perdu la guerre
et que tous ces mouvements sont purement
défensifs
du coup lorsqu'il remarque que les
unités allemandes d'élite sont renforcés
et déplacés pour faire face aux alliés
de l'ouest en france
ils ont déduisent que ce sont des
préparatifs pour contrer l'attaqué
inéluctable des alliés pour traverser le
rhin
[Applaudissements]
en face de cet imposant alignement de
troupes se trouve différentes unités
américaines la deuxième division et la
99e division d'infanterie font partie du
cinquième corps us sous les ordres du
général joao
ils tiennent une position face à la
sixième armée de panzers au centre la
28e division et la 106e division
d'infanterie qui font partie du viiième
corps du général treuil middleton font
face à man the fun au sud les hommes de
la 9e division blindée et de la
quatrième division d'infanterie campent
devant les troupes de brandon burger la
plupart de ces unités américaines sont
dans la région pour se reposer après les
récents combats
toutes ses unités totalisent environ 83
mille soldats soutenue par près de 450
chars et autres blindés et 400 pièces
d'artillerie
[Musique]
ces hommes se retrouvent dans un pays
étranger à une d époque de l'année les
plus mornes et la plupart d'entre eux
pensent à leur foyer et à noël
ils se sont tous déjà rudement battu
contre l'ennemi est la dernière chose
qu'il souhaite c'est de se retrouver
confrontés à une attaque d'une telle
envergure
or les ardennes sont un secteur tenu par
des divisions américaines assez faible
l'une d'entre elles la 106e n'a aucune
expérience n'a jamais combattu et les
deux autres la 28e division d'infanterie
et la 4e division blindée ont subi de
lourdes pertes dans les combats dans la
forêt et puis il y à la 9e division
blindée en réserve qui elle non plus n'a
aucune expérience et un groupe de
cavalerie toutes ces unités sont très
dispersées
contrairement aux allemands plusieurs
facteurs jouent en faveur des alliés
bien qu en sous-nombre au départ ils
peuvent compter sur les renforts de
nombreuses troupes bien équipée à qui
l'on peut faire appel en cas de besoin
parmi elles la troisième armée sous les
ordres du général george patton a déjà
connu le combat
[Musique]
à ce stade de la guerre les lignes de
ravitaillement des alliés sont bien
établis et quand le temps le permet ils
ont la maîtrise totale du ciel les
alliés doivent juste retardé les
allemands et attendre que les éléments
leur soient de nouveau favorable
[Musique]
la possibilité pour les alliés de
fournir des renforts venant du nord et
du sud représente un autre danger
significatif pour les allemands
pour parer à cela une attaque menée par
le douzième corps de pompe rss est
prévue en même temps que l'aso général
mais à cause de la situation difficile
sur le front de l'est l'opération est
annulée
par conséquent les flancs des armées
allemandes dans le nord seront à la
merci des renforts anglais sous les
ordres du maréchal montgomery
le moral et l'humeur générale des
troupes du nord-ouest de l'europe à la
veille de noël sont au plus bas des
empreintes de résignation et ch
il est clair que l'émulation et
l'optimisme de l'été 1944 provoqué par
le débarquement de normandie après
lequel beaucoup de gens pensaient que la
guerre serait terminée en quelques
semaines voire quelques mois ont disparu
le temps commence empirer avec une neige
fondante glacial un sentiment d'ennui
commence à s'emparer de beaucoup de
soldats alliés il affecte
particulièrement les américains les
anglais sont moins touchés parce que la
grande bretagne et surtout londres sont
toujours victimes de bombardements de v
1 et 2 et 2 les britanniques restent
donc très motivé pour aller de l'avant
et pour infliger de plus de dégâts
possibles aux allemands
par contre le mal du pays s'empare d'une
grande partie des américains state
beaucoup ont quitté les états unis
depuis plus de deux ans et passe à leur
deuxième voire leur troisième noël loin
de leurs familles
le matin du 16 décembre à 5h30
l'artillerie allemande ouvre le feu sur
la ligne de front qui fait près de 140
km de long
[Musique]
le tir de barrage intense qui durera
moins d'une heure et surtout destinée à
semer la confusion dans les rangs
ennemis et à briser leurs lignes de
communication les allemands espèrent
aussi ouvrir un passage dans les rangs
alliés
les troupes de lax avance de façon
significative brise les rangs ennemis et
s'infiltre dans certaines régions les
groupes alliés isolés et dépassés sont
soit tués soit fait prisonnier
certaines unités résiste mais cela ne
suffira pas pour arrêter l'avalanche des
troupes allemandes
dans les postes de commandement et les
quartiers généraux alliés à l'arrière
plusieurs officiers tente de se faire
une idée de la situation mais c'est
impossible car les communications sont
rompues et les postes avancés déjà
capturé
après quelques jours les soldats
américains commencent à se rendre un tel
point que c'est encore aujourd'hui le
record du nombre de soldats faits
prisonniers dans l'histoire de l'armée
américaine
[Musique]
toutefois d'autres troupes américaines
réussissent à tenir des places dont
l'importance stratégique s'avérera
crucial
la crête des zones borno nord
s'invite au centre et bastogne au sud
dé
le plan d'attaqué basé sur l'idée que la
sixième armée de panzers bien équipé et
constitué de waffen ss bien entraînées
et capables de frapper les américains et
de les défaire facilement
avant de poursuivre tout droit jusqu'à
la crête d'elsenborn et la meuse
mais ça ne se passera pas comme ça
à partir de là c'est la course vers les
objectifs prioritaires
les allemands savent que le temps n'est
pas de leur côté et qu'ils doivent
atteindre leur but rapidement
pourtant les choses commencent à mal se
passer pour eux
au nord le parachutage prévu sur les
halls borne est effectué sous une météo
épouvantable
les allemands devait capturer la crête
d'elsenborn le plus vite possible
pour continuer leur route au nord et
atteindre la meuse le contrôle de ce
sommet est indispensable c'est une
mission parfaite pour une opération est
reportée mais celle ci sera un vrai
désastre
les parades allemands sont sous les
ordres d'un vétéran le colonel vendeur
ait il saute au dessus d'une vaste zone
mais seront incapables de concentrer
leurs efforts
les allemands qui n'ont pas fait de
missions de reconnaissance sotteville au
dessus des positions de la première à
fatri us elles se rendent compte que les
forces américaines sont plus puissantes
que prévu
quand ils comprennent qu'ils ne pourront
pas remplir leurs objectifs ils tentent
de briser les lignes ennemies en force
après avoir subi de lourdes pertes les
parages allemands battent en retraite et
s'infiltre derrière les lignes
américaines par petits groupes
cette unité comptait 1200 hommes et à
peine 350 réussiront à se battre côte à
côte suite à leur dispersion
- 200 survivants parviendront à
rejoindre leur ligne
evans de wright sera fait prisonnier
le seul véritable succès de cette petite
mission sera de donner l'impression aux
alliés d'avoir affaire à un nombre
d'ennemis bien plus importants qu'en
réalité les obligeant à allouer un grand
nombre de leurs soldats pour contrer
cette menace virtuelle
[Musique]
si le premier corps de panzer ss avait
avancé plus vite il aurait pu profiter
de cet avantage
mais il rencontre a lui aussi des
difficultés
depuis le début de l'offensive
la 99e division us se défend âprement et
réussi à garder le contrôle de collines
stratégique
l'avant-garde du 1er régiment de pannes
seraient cesse le groupe de combat piper
continuera son mouvement vers l'ouest
jusqu'à handcent
l'unité qui doit absolument réussir sa
mission pour garantir le succès de la
6ème harnais de panzers et c'est sympa
c'est un groupe de combat dirigée par
johan kim piper
et il n'a que 48 heures pour atteindre
la meuse mais il va très vite accumulé
du retard pris peur et habitué à opérer
sur le front de l'est avec de grandes
plaines des terrains vallonnés
et quand il organise sa formation de
marche en occident il place de façon
assez logique ces véhicules lourds comme
les panneaux heures et les nouveaux
jarre tigres en tête de colonne
mais ce qui n'a pas prévu c'est la
faible vitesse de pointe de ses chars
qui vont ralentir sous la colonne il
doit progresser avec ses énormes chars
de 68 tonnes à travers de petites routes
sur de petits ponts et pendant sa
progression il rencontre des petites
poches de résistance américaine qui se
jette en travers de sa route et
l'obligent à changer de cap les
allemands doivent changer plusieurs fois
de route au point que piper commencent à
se retrouver sur le territoire destiné à
l'aso centrale
au sud la 5ème armée de panzers connaît
un meilleur début
ces hommes rencontrent la 28e division
et la 106e division d'infanterie très
dispersé et qui ne sont pas encore
prêtes pour le combat
les allemands passent à travers ces
unités assez facilement cependant
quelques groupes américains réussissent
à ralentir leur avance et à garder le
contrôle de plusieurs ponts de la région
mais à la fin du premier jour les hommes
de michael force le passage de la
rivière omo et fonce sur clairvaux sans
perdre de temps
la troisième force de la tacc la 7e
armée de brandenburger plus au sud
connaît de grosses difficultés à cause
de la nature du terrain et de la
détermination des défenseurs américains
du 109e régiment us
le som l'effort des allemands va très
rapidement s'effondrer à cause de la
résistance américaine combinée à des
erreurs logistiques comme par exemple le
fait que toute cette offensive a lieu
alors que les effectifs ne sont pas au
complet
le 17 décembre toutes les unités
allemandes sont impliqués dans l'effort
offensif malgré les difficultés
rencontrées
de son côté le haut commandement
américain commencent à réagir et a
envoyé des renforts dans la région
parmi eux se trouve la 7e et la 10e
division blindée et la 101e division
aéroportée
cette dernière reçoit l'ordre de marché
sur bastogne le point de jonction de
plusieurs routes le plus important de
toute la région la course contre la
montre est maintenant lancée
[Musique]
au nord les allemands poursuivent leurs
efforts pour remplir leurs objectifs
le commandant du premier corps et cesse
commence à être frustrés de la lenteur
de la progression
il ordonne à la 12e division de panzer
ss alors impliqué dans les combats
autour de la crête des hellbourne de
faire mouvement derrière la première
division de panzers et cesse en route
vers l'amblève
il s'agit là de la première grosse
erreur fait pendant l'offensive
puisqu'elle permet de relâcher la
pression sur les troupes alliées qui
défendent la région
les américains ne perdent pas de temps
et fortifie leur position à un point tel
que les allemands ne réussiront jamais à
les prendre
petit peloton d'infanterie américains
réussissent à tenir leurs positions sur
les petites routes des communes
ardennaises
comme ils ne sont plus en contact avec
leurs supérieurs personne ne leur a
donné des ordres pour faire ce qu'ils
font ils se débrouillent donc pour
organiser leur défense
c'est quelque chose de très important
la seule façon d'arrêter une attaque de
blindés allemands c'est par une défense
en profondeur
c'est à dire que vous n'essayez pas de
tenir une ligne de défense vous vous
retrancher sur des positions bien
défendu et vous obligez l'ennemi de se
battre pour prendre ses poches et s'il
vous qu'on tourne vous pouvez contre
attaquer les américains n'ont pas prévu
ce type de défense
aux cours de l'avancée de la première
division ss le groupe de combat piper
sera impliqué dans une escarmouche près
de beaune et ce qui suivra fera l'objet
de nombreux débats
ce qui est indéniable c'est que près de
80 prisonniers de guerre américains
seront abattus
les américains affirmeront qu'ils ont
été tués de sang froid
les allemands prétendront qu'il tentait
de s'échapper
[Musique]
le 17 décembre ne patrouille américaine
de reconnaissance découvre les corps de
ces soldats massacré étendu dans la
neige
les allemands en particulier les waffen
ss ont donc commencé à utiliser sur le
front de l'ouest les méthodes qu'ils
utilisaient sur le front de l'est
comme cela se passe souvent dans les
armées le bruit se répand très
rapidement en
moins de trois quarts d'heure tous les
soldats américains dans les ardennes
savait que les allemands ne faisait pas
de prisonniers
et dans ces cas là il n'y a que deux
choses à faire soit vous fuyez soit vous
ne pouvez pas fuir ont vu et vous vous
battez
pas le groupe de combat piper et
certains éléments de la waffen ss ont
donc involontairement décuplée l'ardeur
au combat des américains dans les
ardennes
sans perdre de temps piper et
approvisionne s'écharpant heures en
carburant et continue sa marche vers la
ville de save l'eau et son pont vital
mais arriver là son avance est stoppée
pendant quelques heures à cause de la
résistance des alliés piper ne
connaissant pas l'importance des forces
qui se posent à lui préfère reporter la
progression au lendemain le 18 décembre
stavelot tombe entre ses mains elle
continue jusque trois ponts
dans cette ville plusieurs ponts
enjambent les rivières de la salm et de
l'amblève à la proche du groupe de piper
les défenseurs américains font sauter
les ponts pour empêcher les allemands de
les utiliser
la seule solution pour piper consiste à
l'heure à faire demi tour
ils tentent d'atteindre chenaux ou un
autre pont traversant amblève mais se
fait attaquer par l'aviation américaine
[Musique]
arrivé à ce point la puissante première
division de pannes n'auraient c'est ce
sera obligé de s'arrêter
[Musique]
la dernière grande offensive de la
guerre sur le front de l'ouest se
terminera dans le petit village de la
glaise la majorité des hommes de paille
peur ils recevront l'ordre d'organiser
leur défense
le facteur carburant a joué un rôle
crucial dans l'échec de cette partie du
plan d'attaqué des allemands quand ils
atteignent les villages de la glaise et
de stoumont les réservoirs de leurs
chats sont en effet presque à sec
les allemands attendent beaucoup des
troupes ss et quand les officiers du
quartier général apprennent que piper
est obligé de rester à la glaise ils ne
perdent pas tant tout le poids de
l'offensive est alors reporté sur le
secteur de la 5ème armée de panzers qui
a pu profiter d'un terrain plus
favorable et de la faiblesse des soldats
de la 106e division us
9 la 5ème armée de panzers sous les
ordres de wendel faisait partie de la
wehrmacht l avance et en profitant du
pays et d'utiliser les routes
principales la 5ème armée se retrouve
dans une drôle de situation elles
progressent à l'ouest ce qui peut
sembler bien sûr seul problème c'est que
ce n'est pas la bonne direction les
allemands doivent aller vers le nord
ils poursuivent leur course pour
atteindre leurs objectifs dont l'un des
plus importants est la ville de bastogne
la ville joue un rôle crucial parce que
c'est là que convergent plusieurs routes
faisant d'elle un centre de voies de
communication
pourtant les allemands sont coiffés au
poteau par les soldats de la 101e
division aéroportée
ses vétérans du débarquement de
normandie et de l'opération market
garden ont établi un périmètre défensif
tout autour de la ville
quand les allemands tentent de percer
ses positions ils se rendent compte que
c'est impossible
michael ordonne alors à ses hommes de ne
plus perdre de temps et de contourner la
ville pour poursuivre leur avance créant
ainsi une solide poches de résistance et
demi au sein des positions allemandes
toutes les tentatives pour éliminer
cette poche engloutiront un nombre
considérable d'hommes et de matériels
jeunes chercheurs l'effet de surprise
qui avait frappé les américains est
passé eisenhower a réagi et dans les 60
heures il ordonne à ses troupes de faire
mouvement pour contrer l'offensive dans
les ardennes les renforts du nord et du
sud sont envoyés en avant et en quelques
jours l'offensive des allemands est
obligé de s'arrêter même si les combats
ont duré plus d'un mois
le 22 décembre les allemands envoie un
émissaire avec un drapeau blanc à
bastogne pour proposer aux américains
une reddition
la réponse du commandant de la garnison
le général mc auliffe elle a connu des
clos
au même moment plus au nord les
allemands ont finalement réussi à
prendre s'invite ce succès est
particulièrement important puisqu'il
s'agit d'un des points clés des routes
du plan de progression
les combats pour prendre la ville ont
pris plusieurs jours
et comme pour d'autres secteurs ces
retards ont permis aux américains de
consolider leur défense à l'arrière
le jour du réveillon de noël 1944 les
troupes de man the fun atteignent la
région à l'ouest de la ville de sel les
allemands ne dépasseront jamais ce point
au cours de l'offensive
[Musique]
le jour de noël la ville de bastogne est
soumise à la pression croissante des
allemands mais grâce à la maîtrise du
ciel par les alliés la garnison peut
être ravitaillée par les airs sans
craindre l'intervention des ennemis les
défenseurs de la ville sont prêts à se
battre jusqu'à la fin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 26 décembre
des éléments de l'armée de patton
réussissent à se frayer un passage en
force à travers les lignes allemandes
jusque dans bastogne
après cette opération de renfort la
situation des allemands deviendra vite
sans espoir
dans les derniers jours de décembre 1944
il est clair que les moyens de
l'offensive allemande sont largement
épuisé
ils ont gaspillé d'énormes quantités de
carburant la plus grande partie de
l'émission et leurs avants gardes ont
subi de lourdes pertes lors des combats
contre les américains
en plus ils ont largement échoué à
couper les lignes de communication
autour d'eux une borne au nord et autour
de boston au sud
les américains en ont profité pour
consolider leur position
même s'ils ont réussi à prendre des
lignes de communication autour de saint
vite ce n'est tout simplement pas assez
pour leur permettre de continuer les
changements de météo joue en plus en
faveur des alliés au début de
l'offensive dans les ardennes les
allemands profitent de la couverture
nuageuse et de la neige pour se protéger
des avions alliés
cependant
à partir du 23 décembre 1944 le temps
dans la région refroidi
le ciel s'éclaircit et leur protection
contre les chasseurs et les bombardiers
alliés disparaît
les pilotes alliés peuvent enfin faire
rugir leur moteur au dessus des zones de
combat et ainsi précipité la défaite des
armées ennemies l'aviation vient en
appui des troupes au sol par alice tout
mouvement de troupes allemandes surtout
des colonnes d'approvisionnement et
ravitaille par les airs les unités
américaines encerclé
un des événements les plus
extraordinaires de la bataille sera
aussi dévoilée la 150e brigade de pfizer
était aussi l'une des clefs de
l'offensive allemande ses troupes
obéissent aux ordres de otto skorzeny un
meneur d'hommes courageux
ils reçoivent l'ordre de s'enfoncer loin
derrière les lignes ennemies et 10
causer un maximum de dégâts et de
confusion ils doivent aussi s'emparer de
gué de rivière cruciaux et les tenir le
temps que le gros des forces arrive
il utilise des jeeps et des camions
capturée aux américains et maquis leur
char pour les faire ressembler à ceux
des alliés en réalité seuls quelques
individus atteindront la meuse mais
elles devront abandonner leurs positions
par manque de support adéquat
plusieurs de leurs groupes se feront
capturé à ce moment-là par les
américains qui s'interrogent
sérieusement sur ce qui se trame la
rumeur se répandra rapidement que des
allemands déguisé en allié au père
derrière les lignes que c'est uniquement
le rôle de ce corps zenny est assez
important puisqu'il provoque un
sentiment de panique jusqu'aux saintes
du quartier général d'eisenhower
la rumeur selon laquelle il y à des
commandos derrière les lignes
américaines se répand parmi les soldats
si d'un côté les commandos de scorer ni
sont un échec d'un autre côté ils ont en
effet majeur en déstabilisant
psychologiquement les alliés effect
jusqu'où un commandement suprême
l'effet psychologique de ce petit groupe
sur le moral des alliés dépasse
largement leurs petits nombres la
paranoïa n'épargne personne et
eisenhower sera lui-même confinés dans
ces quartiers par crainte d'un attentat
dans le village de la glaise piper se
rend compte que la situation devient
désespérée pour lui et ses hommes qui
subissent le bombardements ininterrompus
de l'artillerie et des chars alliés les
américains déterminé à écraser leurs
ennemis tireront plus de 58 milles au
but au cours de la bataille
piper est habitué à se sortir de
situations épineuses comme il l'a
souvent fait en russie en normandie
il ordonne la destruction des chars et
de half track encore en service pour
qu'il ne tombe pas aux mains des alliés
les réservoirs sont vides et n'y a plus
de munitions
il laisse une poignée de ses hommes en
arrière pour donner l'impression de
continuer le combat et pour surveiller
les 150 prisonniers américains et il
emmène avec lui un groupe de 800
survivants vers les lignes allemandes
la tentative est risqué et plus d'une
fois ils devront affronter des groupes
d'américains qui se trouve en travers de
leur chemin
ils réussiront finalement à atteindre
les lignes a mis quelques jours plus
tard
au départ piper avait 5000 hommes sous
ses ordres et ses pertes en hommes et en
matériels seront impossibles a remplacé
avant la fin de la guerre
[Musique]
dans le secteur de manta fun les
américains élargissent doucement le
corridor des renforts vers bastogne la
férocité des combats augmentent en
intensité et rapidement la région
deviendra le centre de toutes les
convoitises pour les deux camps les
alliés envoie plusieurs unités en
renfort dans la ville y compris la 4e
division blindée la 26e division et la
80e division d'infanterie la bataille
des ardennes comme l'appellent les
américains sera marquée par de rudes
combats pour les deux camps
à mesure que les alliés renforcent leurs
troupes dans la région il repousse
lentement les allemands
le 2 janvier 1945 la ligne de front a
reculé de 15 km
c'est aussi à cette époque que les
anglais entrent en jeu
dès le début de l'offensive
montgomerie avait placé deux solides
unités britanniques en position
défensive le long de la meuse devinant
que le fleuve serait capital pour les
allemands il avait reçu le commandement
de certaines troupes américaines
nord a pris une décision politique qui
aurait pu être très dangereuse qui l'a
nommé montgomery commandant en chef dans
le nord et ce commandement amputer une
partie des troupes américaines
d'un point de vue politique américain
cela pouvait passer pour une erreur mais
ce fut la bonne décision montgomery
commença à resserrer le front
bien que peu de troupes britanniques
soient vraiment confrontés directement à
l'offensive allemande le rôle des
onglets mérite d'être mentionné quand
les armées britanniques prennent la
décision de consolider les défenses sur
la meuse au début de l'offensive cela a
certainement permis aux américains de
libérer des troupes et les envoyer se
battre dans les artères
et en plus en donnant à montgomery la
charge de commander les troupes
américaines et anglaises sur le nord de
la progression des allemands cela a
permis de créer un commandement bien
plus approprié pour s'occuper de
l'offensive que si les américains
avaient été en charge de tout le secteur
quand ils pensent que le moment est venu
montgomery lance sa contre attaque vers
les lignes ennemies avec pour objectif
de rejoindre les américains plus au sud
le 4 janvier l'objectif est atteint
quand ces hommes atteignent enfin la
ville de la roche
ceci mettra définitivement la meuse hors
d'atteinte pour les allemands
alors que les généraux allemands et
leurs troupes réalise le côté désespéré
de la situation est claire en est
incapable il ordonne la poursuite de la
progression et la prise des objectifs
mais à ce stade la difficulté devient
insurmontable
les chasseurs alliés déversent leur flot
de bombes sur les troupes de lax comme
il l'avait déjà fait en normandie
début janvier une lueur d'espoir renaît
chez les allemands quand la louve toif
lance son propre raid avec environ 1000
avions contre des cibles et des terrains
d'aviation alliés ils réussiront à
détruire environ 300 avions alliés et
endommagé 25 terrains mais cela au prix
de 100 appareils est sans doute plus
grave encore de la perte de pilotes
expérimentés et irremplaçable
au total les allemands perdrons 170
pilotes et 67 seront faits prisonniers
finalement le rêve de la louve toif sera
un revers de plus
vers le milieu du mois de janvier
certaines unités allemandes commenceront
à se retirer de la ligne de front parmi
elles la première division de panzers et
c'est ce qui a beaucoup souffert durant
l'opération
les unités restantes subiront encore
plus de pertes suite à l'affaiblissement
général de leurs forces
à la fin du mois de janvier la ligne de
front a retrouvé les mêmes marques qu'au
début de l'offensive
six semaines plus tôt
le prix à payer est lourd pour les deux
camps les alliés ont perdu environ 75
mille hommes les allemands perdent près
de 120 mille soldats et la perte d'un
nombre important de chars irremplaçable
et autres véhicules
le dernier coup de poker d'hitler sera
un échec
[Musique]
oh